as the impeachment hearings were
underway on Capitol Hill President Trump
was meeting with Turkey's president at
the White House and CBS News has
confirmed that there was a surprise
confrontation when Turkey's president
that's President Erdogan met with mr.
Trump and others in the Oval Office
Paula Reid is at the White House so
Paula good morning what's this all about
a surprise indeed Tony during this
meeting the president brought several
Republican senators into the Oval Office
to meet with turkeys leader in a hope in
a hope to ease some of the hard feelings
because several of these senators have
been very critical of turkeys action
particularly in northern Syria now we're
told during this meeting the leader of
Turkey pulled out his iPad and showed a
propaganda video depicting the US allies
the Kurds as terrorists apparently the
Turkish leader thought that he could
sway some of these senators by showing
them this clunky propaganda video but
hurlan de senators took turns pushing
back on the Turkish leader now the GOP
senators they had a goal in mind too
they had showed up to this meeting to
try to help convince Turkey not to buy
Russian military equipment they hoped
that they could work with the president
to convince turkey instead to buy
American hardware but it turns out this
meeting overall appears that it wound up
being a pretty awkward and it doesn't
appear that anyone's hearts or minds
were changed Paula thank you very much